an executive producer at Marvel Studios
has confirmed that the TVA is going to
be around in the MCU for a long time and
affect other projects he stated in an
interview yesterday the TVA is an
organization that will continue to have
stories to tell which is one of the
exciting things about it to us and this
right here could be Loki's glorious
purpose as it turns out Loki might have
been thinking a little bit too small
when he tried to conquer Earth because
he could possibly conquer the entire
Multiverse by being the leader of the
TVA of course it seems like he would do
things differently or will he will he
reign in benevolence or will he
ultimately decide that they do need to
prune timelines killing everyone in that
timeline in order to save the sacred
timeline and keep the entire Multiverse
from shattering what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm laurren Thompson and this is
what Loki is currently dealing with in
Loki season 2 episode 1 when he gets
back back and he starts talking to
Mobius in the present time he states
that he doesn't know what the right
choice was he tells Mobius that he got
to the man at the end of time and he was
right he who remains was right and this
is something we are going to see Loki
struggle with throughout the entire
season we've even seen in the trailers
Loki and Sylvie talking where Sylvie
says we're playing God and Loki says we
are Gods so is it our Gods Loki and
sylv's Destiny to rule the TVA just like
he who remains said I believe that this
could be how Loki season 2 ends with
Loki and possibly and hopefully Sylvie
ruling over the TVA as we've discovered
in the finale of Loki season 1 and in
the post credit scene of Loki season 2
episode 1 Loki and Sylvie do not see he
who remains and the TVA the same way in
the finale Loki fought Sylvie trying to
get her to just take a second and think
about what the right option was should
they kill he who remains or should they
simply take his place the big question
being is he who remains right was he
right by creating the TVA by pruning all
of the other timelines and only keeping
one timeline so he could keep the other
variants of Nathaniel Richards AKA King
the Conqueror AKA he who remains and
anybody else that's going to come into
play like Victor timley was that the
right move well Loki is struggling with
this but he has already said a few
things that make us believe that he does
indeed believe he who remains was right
when Loki finally gets to the present
and talks to Mobius he tells him I just
wanted more time to think and he says
that it was an impossible choice and he
says that Sylvie was so certain but how
could she be given the consequences so
Loki believed he who remains he
understood the consequences he heard
what he was saying loud and clear but
now he's gone and Loki knows that he
said it was up to him and Sylvie to run
the TVA now or he was coming a bunch of
different variants of him infinite
variants of him were going to come and
and they're going to start a multiversal
war but Loki drops a huge bomb when
talking to Mobius he says Mobius we got
to the man at the end of time and he
made sense we thought it was about
freeing the timeline but that brings
only more malevolence more violence more
war more of him they're coming they're
all coming he also goes on to say maybe
it's true everything he was doing the
preservation of the Sacred timeline the
pruning it was all about preventing more
of him there was no simple choice but
then Loki says there was no other way so
it's very clear from this dialogue that
we hear with him speaking to Mobius that
he actually believes he who remains made
sense and was right but what does this
mean for the future of Loki like I said
I believe that Loki could be destined to
rule the entire TVA and rule the
Multiverse however I don't think he's
going to do this by pruning all of these
different timelines instead I think it's
going to be more about monitoring them
and maintaining them and I have a theory
of how they could do this and it does
involve sort of a multiversal Avengers
team which According to some reports we
are supposed to see in Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars we've talked about
this team before we'll go over it again
really briefly and talk about how Loki
will rule the TVA but first big thank
you to hellofresh for sponsoring this
video many of you probably know by now
that I personally use hellofresh a lot
because for me it simply makes sense I
have a pretty busy schedule in my
day-to-day life and hellofresh just
makes eating good meals a lot easier for
me with over 40 different recipes that I
could choose from each week hellofresh
does all the shopping and meal planning
for you ingredients arrive at your
doorstep pre-portioned and ready to cook
along with pictured step-by-step recipe
cards they literally make it as easy as
it possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15minute meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout out that means
less stress of worrying about what
you're going to eat and you save money
so if interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping so according to
some recent reports from some insiders
and some confirmations from some big
Outlets as well the TVA is going to be a
part of Deadpool 3 and like I read to
you in the beginning executive producer
Kevin Wright over at Marvel Studios did
confirm that the TVA is going to play a
role in the MCU moving forward and
here's what he had to say in an
interview with deadline when talking
about if there's going to be another
season of Loki and if Loki season 2 is
going to affect other properties
deadline asked does Loki season 2 like
other Marvel series bridge to another
big movie in the near future clearly the
next Avengers King Dynasty but are there
others he said nothing I could say in
the near future I have something to say
about this but let's finish what he said
he says the implications will Ripple
into other projects though certainly and
the TVA is an organization that will
continue to have stories to tell which
is one of the exciting things about it
to us so he confirms Loki season 2 and
the TVA will go into other projects
which totally makes sense because this
is the Multiverse Saga Loki season 2 is
all about the Multiverse and trying to
actually control the Multiverse now he
says nothing in the near future but we
know how this works if there is
something that's about to happen happen
like the TVA or Loki and Mobius being in
Deadpool 3 he can't just come out and
say that they've signed ndas plus Kevin
fugy has the sniper to his head of
course so he says no not in the near
future but then he goes on to say yes it
bleeds into other projects certainly so
this is basically yes expect Loki or the
TVA or Mobius or something from Loki
season 2 to pop up in other projects I
would say soon then they talk about
where the story arc of Loki is going to
go and if it's going to go beyond season
2 now if Loki is going to go on to
control the TVA and be the ruler of the
TVA I would definitely think that it's
going to go past Loki season 2 and would
go into at least other projects where
the TVA is heavily involved and the
Multiverse is heavily involved like
Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars now insiders
have told us that while the Multiverse
is starting to have a lot of incursions
happen the TVA is going to go around to
different universes and they will save
selected Heroes then they'll put them on
one world together battle world then
when Secret Wars comes the TVA is going
to send a team to help the Earth 616
Heroes this team is going to be sort of
a Multiverse Avengers team which I think
the TVA is going to implement in the
future for keeping control over the
Multiverse insiders state that this team
is going to be led by Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine Toby McGuire Spider-Man and
Deadpool I hope the reports about this
are accurate because I really want to
see this Toby McGuire Spider-Man and
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine are my
childhood Heroes so finger crossed this
is real and if it is real it does seem
like the TVA sort of has a tactic here
using a group of multiversal Heroes who
are super strong and powerful to help
other timelines so let's take it back to
how Loki and Sylvie feel both of them
want free will however the big question
that Loki is asking himself right now is
that if they give the entire Multiverse
free will will that destroy the
Multiverse it's not that he doesn't want
people to have it it's that it could
destroy everything Sylvie on the other
hand sort of just set out to do one
thing destroy the person who made her
entire life hell the person in charge of
the TVA she ran from the TVA her entire
life they took her from her home they
took everything from her and she just
wanted to bring it down so she didn't
really care about the consequences cuz
she got her revenge but the main point
of Loki episode 1 in the war room with
Hunter B5 and Mobius and general docs
and judge gamble was that they cannot
prune timelines anymore because those
are people millions billions trillions
of people so it's going to come back to
that what do they do with the TVA do do
they keep one sacred timeline or do they
let it Branch out well Loki understands
that if they let it Branch out Kang is
going to come his variants are going to
come and most likely probably some other
villains as well every now and then but
there is an option of where Loki can let
it Branch out but he could monitor what
is happening in each timeline they could
simply Look for King the Conqueror
rising in each timeline and when it gets
to that point he could send a
multiversal Avengers X-Men whatever ever
team to go and defeat Kang the Conqueror
that way that timeline can still live on
but Kang is no longer a threat in that
timeline this seems to be how they would
do it because if they decide to just
keep one sacred timeline then they have
to prune all the other timelines which
means there isn't really free will
however if they just let it go and have
no monitoring or control whatsoever the
multiversal war will happen so this
seems to be one of the only ways to
where they could actually give people
free will which is what Loki and Sylvie
want but Loki and Sylvie are Gods so it
does seem like they would be pretty fit
to rule the TVA I'm sure Mobius would
pretty much be the man in charge but
Loki would sort of be like he who
remains or the fake timekeepers and I'm
sure Loki would kind of want to get his
hands dirty as well going in with this
multiversal team to try and defeat Kang
in these certain timelines and of course
they'll pretty much figure out how to do
it instantly after fighting him several
several times and hopefully they would
intervene before he became super
powerful the TVA has the technology to
know when somebody does something
they're not supposed to do in a timeline
and it starts to Branch they know the
exact moment when somebody does
something wrong and then they're there
to take that person much like in the
beginning of Loki season 1 Loki
disappears with the Tesseract and
they're waiting for him right away so
they could absolutely monitor King the
Conqueror or Nathaniel Richards in every
timeline that he could possibly be in
and when he gets too strong they step in
and if he gets stronger than they could
handle then they could simply prune that
timeline again sort of making sure Kang
doesn't get out of control but still all
of the other timelines could live and
they wouldn't be murdering trillions of
people so based on the way that this
story is going this could be Loki's
glorious purpose to lead the TVA to
essentially kind of control the
Multiverse but as a hero as somebody
who's trying to protect everybody and
that would really be just such an
incredible story arc for Loki to go from
where we saw him in Thor one and then
the villain and Avengers and everything
else we've seen to see him actually be
the savior of the entire Multiverse that
would just be amazing but let us know
what you think about this theory in the
comments down below do you think Loki is
destined to rule the TVA and that is his
glorious purpose or do you think it's
going to end in a different way leave
your thoughts down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X a
PS4 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well we pick one winner at the
end of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item you can also find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolof
woof